something that uh those on the of us on
the right always enjoy
and derive immense satisfaction from
somewhat sick satisfaction perhaps but
satisfaction nonetheless
are stories of the left turning on
itself and its adherence devouring
each other as they are prone do we've
seen this phenomenon many times and
i think it might be interesting and
useful to try and figure out
why this happens exactly but before we
do that let's look at the latest example
and it's a it's a rather
glorious example i must say boston pride
is the group that organizes the city's
pride parade and
other gay activities in the city it's
important to note that this organization
has been around
and active for 50 years okay
um they so presumably one of the oldest
you know gay rights organizations i
would assume in the country
they've been um major significant
players
in the gay rights world and and yet
recently they
had come under fire from within their
own ranks a growing number of lgbt
activists decided that boston pride
is racist because there are too many
white people running the organization
and too many white people attending the
events
now i have no interest in at all in
defending boston pride
but i do feel compelled to point out
that boston pride
would naturally tend to be white simply
because boston the city
is predominantly white unlike many other
cities today like say baltimore which is
uh
62 black in boston the majority of
residents are white
just so happens making it not so
shocking or scandalous that a majority
of boston pride attendees
are white there are many other
scandalous things that happen at those
events no doubt
but that isn't one of them nonetheless
you can't have too many white people
as we have learned or too many quote
cisgender people which was another
problem apparently
and that's why local activists this past
year after
attacking boston pride as racist and
even transphobic
decided to boycott the traditional event
the traditional pride event that i've
been going on for 50 years and hold
their own
so this past month on june 12th 12th
you may have missed this i'm sorry if
you did but they had their first annual
trans resistance march and vigil led by
they said
queer and trans people of color an
article posted to
boston.com last month explains the
reasoning for this competing event
it says queer trans and black indigenous
people of color
by poc activists have been calling on
boston pride to make changes since at
least 2015 when black lives matter
demanded the organization diversify the
board
allow bypoc activists control of black
and latino pride events
and re-examine corporate sponsorships
among other things last summer numerous
boston pride volunteers
resigned after the organization
allegedly removed a statement supporting
black lives matter from a newsletter
and called for all board members to step
down in place of more representative
leadership
according to the boston globe boston
pride's six-member six-members board has
no black members
two latino members and one transgender
member
quote my experience in working with the
board is they experience
um community voices as antagonistic
as opposed to thinking these are our
people this according to joe
triglio who resigned from the boston
pride communications team
telling the globe quote they treat that
as some sort of attack as opposed to
what it is
people asking them to serve their needs
and interests
only one transgender board member at a
six outrageous
now we know of course that trans people
comprise far less than one percent of
the population
but they must in any case comprise at
least 50 percent
of every organization board committee
panel
and television show cast how can that
even be possible i mean how can you take
so few trans people
and spread them so widely and visibly
that's your problem figure it out you
have to be like jesus multiplying the
loaves and fishes
multiply the trans that's a you got to
figure out a way to do it
whatever you need to do get it done the
point is simply that this tiny fraction
of the population
must be seen everywhere all the time
without exception
and boston pride they failed in that
regard just as they failed by
allowing too many white people to
participate
and that's what ultimately led to this
as nbc reports today after 50 years
boston pride is disbanding and
dissolving itself in shame
for the sin of being too white and also
two
not trans this according to nbc it says
quote
boston pride the organization that has
organized the city's pride celebrations
for 50 years has announced it is
shutting down
the dissolution announced friday
afternoon in a statement on the group's
website
comes after the reportedly all-white
board of directors has faced ongoing
accusations of ignoring racial
minorities and transgender people
it is clear to us that our community
needs and wants change without the
involvement of boston pride the board
said in a statement we have heard the
concerns of the
qtbi boc community and others
uh the qt bipot community and others the
statement continued referring to queer
and transgender people of color
we care too much to stand in the way
therefore boston pride is dissolving
there will be no further events or
programming planned
and the board is taking steps to close
down the organization the board said the
decision quote was made with a heavy
heart
out of love and hope for a better future
now you might be thinking this is
hilarious
and great a bunch of left-wing gay
activists just nuked our own
organization for no reason at all
what's not to love and you're right it
is indeed hilarious and great but aside
from pointing and laughing it might as i
said be instructive to talk about
why this sort of thing happens because
it happens a lot
and to that end i think there are three
factors to consider
the first is this very simply
blm exercises complete and total power
on the left
and they know it nobody on that side of
the ideological divide
will oppose them or whisper the
slightest objection
even as blm swoops in and eviscerates
its own allies for no discernible reason
leftists have already set the precedent
that opposing black lives matter
the organization means opposing black
lives matter
the concept now usually the left can
violate its own precedence at will
one standard for us another standard for
them but this is one
that even they have to abide by even
they can't get away with violating this
standard
two there's the victim hierarchy now as
as we know by now victimhood is power on
the left which means that there is a
constant struggle within its own ranks
to claim the status of uber victim
that's why the top spot
on the victim pyramid has changed hands
several times over the years
especially in recent years as one group
and then another plants its flag there
as it stands right now the coveted
territory
belongs to bipoc as they now call
themselves black and indigenous people
of color
but it's not enough to be just black or
indigenous
the top of the top the ultimate power
spot belongs to those who can add
additional identities especially
sexualized identities
which has given rise to now qtbi poc or
queer and trans black indigenous people
of color
boston pride was a mere lgbt
organization
they didn't they didn't make a move to
innovate and become a qtbi poc
lgbt organization and as such have been
left in the dust
a tragic tale as old as time three i
think most importantly
and the most fundamental reason why you
see the left eat itself in this way so
often
is that the entire ideology is
intentional
intensely and almost solely self-focused
there cannot be any true community as
much as they talk about community
and they have so many different
communities
and they talk about things like being an
ally or
ally ship that can't exist
camaraderie loyalty none of that exists
because they're all looking constantly
back within themselves i mean to be
a member of a real community to have
real camaraderie and loyalty
you have to look outward you have to be
concerned about
something other than just yourself
but they aren't that's the defining
feature of leftism it's an ideology a
religion
of the self
that is what it is at its core at its
base
and it's how they come up with all these
new self identities and why they believe
the whole world should cooperate with
and affirm whatever new identities they
invent
it's how we end up with um here's the
latest uh
it's how we end up with with nonsense
like this watch
so i'm not an expert or an authority on
what neural queer means
but to simplify it and make it easier
for you to understand it's essentially
um on a base level it's kind of where
your
neurodivergent identity and your queer
identity how they
interact and intersect this also extends
to your other identities such as your
race
your socio-economic class your ethnicity
etc and how those things also interact
and intersect with your neurodivergence
and your queerness and some ways that
some people may practice being
neuroqueer can range from
theoretical thought experiments to
social justice work methods
a good example may be something like
deciding to
represent your gender identity in an
intentionally
queer way as a way to subvert hegemonic
ideas of gender performance
is a fairly new term so it is very fluid
and the possibilities are endless
oh well okay uh subvert hegemonic ideas
of gender performance
she says with piercings in her cheek
now indeed though the possibilities are
endless as she says
neuroqueer why not just another identity
to add to the list
nothing you just heard there there was
not a coherent sentence uttered
throughout that that whole 56 seconds
um this though is what happens
this is another identity invented by
someone who spends almost all of her
time
staring back into the abyss of her own
ego
according to her religion the leftist
religion which is also our state
religion by the way nothing matters so
much as how you
feel and it's not just how you feel
it's another thing that i think people
on the right get wrong
on the left they're always they're so
sensitive they're focused on their
feelings
well let's be more specific it's not how
you feel it's about how you feel about
yourself your feelings about yourself
everything comes back to yourself
now in a weird way this is what makes
leftism alluring
and powerful especially when it comes to
kids and teenagers it's one of the
reasons why
so many kids and teenagers gravitate in
that direction
because they tend already to be
self-focused everyone has that
capacity that inclination that instinct
towards uh egotism and narcissism
but it's also what makes leftism
dysfunctional and volatile and prone to
self-sabotage
and although all of this is very bad for
the country and our future as a
civilization
and our species it is also sometimes at
least
as is the case with this boston pride
story extremely funny
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated